it's gotta be in 15 years as I've been
in here place looks the front all the
old places look different now I'm the
only one ever cared about you and all
that ended an hour ago when you killed
my son I pulled the trigger I killed
Annie man so he was gonna show michael
i'm here asking for my son's life Shawn
he's a good kid he's got a family he
don't deserve this you know there's our
stand I'm comin after your boy with
everything I got and when it's done and
it will be done then I'll let you die
need honey both know why I'm here
Michael
so what happens now
Jones gonna come after you Michael and
if he can't get to you he's gonna go
after your family this got in tonight
tell everyone to get ready Jimmy's
coming right now we're the most wanted
men in the city I know how this works
they're gonna start pulling your life
apart among people at his house all
people at his wife's family's house any
wearing my rougher how the cops they've
got their own motivation
law school
you've got to worry about stanca life
I'm the best chance you've cut listen to
your father for one night one night
a long night Oh Jimmy